all of time as we know it is actually a
flat circle when Anakin was born
somewhere else like the opposing force
an equal and opposite yeah but like a
virgin birth there's every chance that
they have corn today we are talking
about the big reveal at the end of the
first episode of the mandalorian it's
okay if you pause right now you can get
a free week of Disney Plus that's how I
watch it snap and go watch them and
earlier I'm really quick are you don't
gonna pay for it come back and then
you'll see there was this big thing at
the end of the episode we're gonna get
into age someone spoil it just yet but
with me to eventually spoil it and also
elaborate on what the heck's going on
with that thing is of course Erik Bosse
Maude Garrett and then also rapper / rap
/ / podcaster it's not often I stay
rapper / podcaster that's a very common
job now I just I have done so many
podcasts and none are remotely cool in
any way so like rapper doesn't fit here
forward guys also on this episode we're
gonna talk about the scene that was too
insane that's the quote to make it into
the Joker film but real weird we're
gonna talk about what it probably was
okay back to the Mandalorian yes alright
so the new Star Wars series the
Mandalorian dropped its first episode on
Disney Plus we watched it in the middle
of the night uh it is actually great I
think a lot of people are feeling a lot
better about choosing Plus in general
but spoiler warning again if you haven't
seen it yet go watch it come right back
the episode ends with a big reveal the
Mandalorian has been sent to capture a
little baby Yoda but actually it's not
Yoda
most likely as they reincarnate do we
know yet his race we don't it's one of
the biggest mysteries about star wars
universe right it's not even necessarily
a Gobin definitely not but this is a
very rare
species we've seen a few other yoda-like
Shadle had to to cannon wasn't there a
little in the Clone Wars series wasn't
there like a little Yoda in that so
there's been a few yeah but we got a new
one and this one is probably the third
cutest one this one just came up a full
Christmas so that everyone can have the
plush version a hairless Furby that's
great look at it I heard cha-ching yeah
so here's what I want to know what is
the deal with this little baby Yoda like
creature what are they gonna do in the
Mandalorian it seems like this might be
the thrust of the whole first season
there are probably more plausible
explanations for what this thing is but
mine I'm just gonna roast Rob rogue
theory um I'm going to counter with what
you said Phillip I'm gonna just for the
sake of this episode at least say that
that is Yoda we are looking at Yoda as a
50 year old baby using time travel in
the future of this university time
travel back in the actual Yoda that baby
that the that is in that weird little
pod that the Mandalorian uncovers we are
looking at Yoda as a child that brought
to the future that is he was born the
same year as Anakin Skywalker but we're
looking at a time loop that is in the
process of uncoiling so imagine the
scenario that we saw presented in Star
Wars rebels in which time travel is
possible and is canonical in the Star
Wars universe there are portals that go
through the world between worlds
Palpatine knows of their existence
that's how we use to you know explain
that theory that Shmi and Rey it could
be the same person I don't know if
that's true but I think it is possible
that this Yoda is the same or this
creature is the same Yoda that we know
and hundreds of years in the future the
timeline will Bend back on itself so
that at the beginning of the Phantom
Menace and the the history of the Star
Wars universe as we know so far we now
get this older yzo de who just seems to
have this infinite knowledge he's gained
it
he's seen what the future is he's a
cheater and I say you're out of all of
the Jedi Yoda was the one who was able
to glimpse the future the most he had
that ability like he was able to kind of
see the path I might some my degrees
with what you're saying is right
wouldn't that make Yoda fraud though
that's what I'm saying right
gotas like uh-oh I wonder what we should
do oh maybe I should let all these young
Padawans get murdered just because you
know that's the order well he wouldn't
have known as a baby you don't have
memories from when you're well maybe you
do because you're a super baby full had
a hair full head of teeth but I don't
remember anything from before the age of
14 so I don't think it's fair to assume
that Yoda is responsible for those the
younglings being slaughtered I think
that's exactly what you're implying that
he had all knowledge but but knowledge
of things that are going to be happening
happened that happened Revenge of the
Sith he was maybe what we'll the same
age as Anakin so Anakin was late 20s at
that point early 20s I should know the
exact age so at that point he's half of
the baby that he is now I don't think
this baby currently is gonna store any
of these memories but a hundred years
from now that thing's gonna start having
memories of things that relevation czar
gonna be made about the force and about
history that just inform the very very
wise
stoicism preaching Yoda that Luke met on
Dagobah what I think is is missing for
me to even wrap my head around this is
where the turnback point is right
because if he's like now this little
infant then you're talking about not you
have mentioned your theory but at some
point he's gonna get essentially him
only will be sent back to the beginning
no one else the cosmic coils of the
cosmos are hard human brain directives
mind around but imagine the the universe
not as a linear timeline as we currently
see it now the easy answer is time
portals and Jedi temples as established
in Star Wars rebels the more interesting
answer for me is that all of time all of
time as we know it is actually a flat
circle and only Yoda is old enough to
live long enough to see that circle
fold back in on itself a couple hundred
years not nine hundred years it's like
right before they cut off yeah and
cookies are not force sensitive as Yoda
is so it's and they dive in a battle
they they get hurt they're used for
slave labor as they were in the Kessel
mines and building the Death Star Yoda
is just small and nimble enough to stay
out of those big fights and to stay
active and have a good diet to live that
full nine hundred years I actually will
say something about that there are so
few of this species and I was wondering
it's like obviously you know biology to
parents must create the child in a way
but I was like well like you need at
least two of them to procreate and I'm
wondering if that theory is correct they
are just continuing this same lifeline
yeah here's another wrinkle to it what
are Genesis
what if gadelle is that same one
creature who has had a sex transition on
the third coil around and the adil is
actually 1800 years old a third clue you
mean body parts they don't have duck
penis disappear just miraculously at one
point in the in the in the prequels yeah
she just suddenly disappears so maybe
yeah someone said that it's like order
66 and then she just got co-op but yeah
but her whole story is a bit of a
mystery as well yeah so she probably
transitioned or is the same one little
green bat-eared creature there's one
here's the only thing that Eric's right
about on this the show is called rogue
theory yes in the comments they're
screaming at me right now I'm sure the
two of you have what is actually the ex
cleric has earned one solid Rogi all
right tablo what do you got what do you
think is the right answer cuz there's
certainly the well you know I liked
time-travel but you know that would be
like every Disney property is gonna be
explained by time-travel where like
frozen to is gonna have time travel oh I
right and every Pixar movie is gonna be
time travel which would be ridiculous I
love this idea already and even though
your meaning is a bad thing just imagine
Buzz and Woody watching the events of
Toy Story 1 and in the Back to the
Future style my theory would be that
it's so the force always has that
opposing force so like good and evil
light and dark so if you look at the age
of Yoda now the baby aura he's like 50
right yeah so if you look back it's like
the same age as when Anakin was born
right right yeah yeah 41 BBY so my
theory would be that when Anakin was
born somewhere else like the opposing
force an equal and opposite yeah but
like a virgin birth somewhere I don't
know who the mom is but they gave birth
to another species without having it it
could be at all virgin birth of this
baby which doesn't make sense with the
timeline dumping the time thing in you
were doing so great no here's what's
really great about it there's a thing
that a lot of people have beef with Rey
right and it's like oh man Bray is is
overpowered and has never needed all
this training there is one thing that is
worth all those people acknowledging
Snoke straight up says about kylo that
kylo is becoming more and more powerful
and that Snoke theorizes that by there
being this level of entity on
essentially the dark side of the force
that the force is gonna calibrate and
create a positive entity on the good
side of the force that is as powerful as
him for the balance for the need for
balance so that would explain why she so
quickly is able to scale up even past
Luke theoretically so it's just doing
the same thing if there was
a force as bad as Anakin you know and it
wouldn't be Luke that that balances that
because Luke was born after Anakin like
was a Anakin was good for a while so
that balance isn't isn't timed correctly
but if it is timed with you know when
Anakin is a bad guy then yeah his match
would have been born at the same time I
love that very interesting well that
actually eliminates the fact that Anakin
ever had a choice to be good it means
his path was chosen for him at birth and
it means that you know that whole will
he won't he know he was so close to
being so good
that's all removed if you apply that
theory but it does give greater agency
to the moment he does make the choice to
kill Palpatine the moment he did finally
have his redemption like you're totally
right up until that point yeah he was
locked in this destined fate but that
moment to defy his master and save his
son that gives it even more like
emotionally it might be more like a sine
wave and a cosine wave where they have
kind of the they constantly are
inverting a constantly balance a
mediator straight around that timeline
no yes no let's bring up timelines again
the one I do like that the idea that
theoretically it implies that Yoda it
goes bad at some planet that would
explain why he murders that kind tree in
last Jedi for no reason Heath or
lightning bolts it yeah but but yeah no
I think your theory doesn't hold up when
we look into it too much so we're
quickly gonna move on another another
rogue II blog I I do like it though
I'm already got alright so this is the
Mandalorian as we know with Bubba Fett
the original the first Mandalorian we
came across the whole story for that
that we were exposed to throughout the
clone was were that the Mandalorian was
the first clone so all of the
stormtroopers and you know we're based
on django django who birthed robot like
they all looked exactly the same so i'm
saying virgin birth okay cool I'm lines
waiting is heavily canon this is
something that we know the technology
was there someone in the Jedi Academy
removed kimono from the archives I don't
know who that is but they this
information was available
and someone who is the only person that
came to kimono or Camino Camino sorry
those archives after that but the whole
thing here is that they are cloning to
create an army I think what the Empire
has realized that with Jedi that is
something that they will never have
control over and that is the most
powerful thing in the galaxy so the best
way to make an army of course is to have
the best person for the job which is a
Jedi and so far we have seen that the
most powerful Jedi whose last of the
distance you can live for 900 years is
Yoda so there's every chance that they
have cloned Yoda to either learn about
midi-chlorians or to learn about the
force or to harness this power unlimited
power that is in this one kind of small
being and with that that is going to be
the biggest asset for the Empire because
you have to understand why the Empire is
putting so much money down credits down
to obtain this child why was this
facility protected by so many rogue
mercenaries is what I'm guessing why you
know have so many bounty hunters gone
there and died why are they protecting
this thing so much and why does the
Empire launch it and my understanding is
yeah it's this the clone so they can
experiment on it and learn from it I'm
gonna put a rogue on the line here you
haven't earned it yet you did with your
efforts great but this is gonna be a
wager okay now this could be seen as
exactly the Ray as a clone theory but
you switch out the word ray for free
Yoda essentially but you can go that way
and just say like well Tibet it's that
or you could say this is the first
attempt to try to clone a Jedi they try
Yoda out this is what this baby is
that's why it's important that they
eliminate this baby maybe it's people
who are like don't let them start
cloning Jedi's and then their second run
at it in six years is where baby names
right I love that okay great that's the
right answer
love thousands of baby Yoda's that's
what you're saying right like I want to
see that on screen yeah just so many
baby Yoda is like flipping around the
room
I mean it sounds very cute certainly and
all of those babies are the same Yoda
just looping back on itself infinite I
do like the Pixar short that would
eventually be just like what do you do
with a thousand baby Yoda
[Laughter]
all right guys give it back to me in a
tweet there is only one Yoda with
infinite timeline loops that's your
tweet great
the force is about balance if you have
Anakin you must have baby Yoda yeah the
clones own mod sounded the most like a
tweet so she gets a quarter Rogie but uh
the rest of them I'm very impressed with
I actually like any of these I have a
feeling that we're all wrong still but
there's another thing I actually think
we're gonna guess correctly our next
topic but before we do that real quick
message from us
hey everyone Eric here and with Rick and
Morty coming back we can announce a new
series called Rick's plane it will be
our official Rick and Morty after show
with special guests from the Rick and
Morty staff you can access it by
subscribing to our Rick's plane podcast
feed and we're calling it Rick's plane
because if it's one thing Rick and Morty
fans love it's splainin to their friends
with each episodes really a bow if you
have ever wondered if mr. meeseeks is a
metaphor for slavery or if pickle rick
is an analogy for painkiller addictions
no you are not overthinking it you're
just broken the way I am because each
episode I'm gonna dive deep into the
black hole of an episode of Rick and
Morty the news season 4 episodes and
leading up to that standout episode some
seasons 1 2 & 3
to decode how each is a secret cry for
help and each episode yeah I'm going
sitting down with special guests from
the show writers voice actors animators
so that they can confirm whether or not
my Rick's planation is legit and give us
some secrets behind these episodes that
we otherwise would never know so
subscribe to explain wherever you get
your podcasts so of all the Rick and
Morty fan
you know you could be the richest rich
guys that was Eric talking to you he's
done now thanks Eric
guys uh there's this insane Joker saying
suppose it didn't make the movie okay so
Joker director Todd Phillips has said in
an interview this week that he had to
cut a bathtub scene from the movie or
risk it exceeding an R rating oh not for
don't get too excited but not because it
was too adult or pornographic or graphic
anything about nudity it was this is the
toughest quote because the scene was
quote - insane - insane for an R rating
so yeah for - insane for the Joker film
- and an R rating so pitch me on your
rogue theory for what could have
possibly been this bathtub scene that
was too insane to be in that Joker bait
oh snap oh I didn't want it to visually
like just pop into my head but it did
I mean mod are you ready no kidding good
we want to know yours so the bathtub
only appeared I think when you know when
a walking was like bathing his mom yeah
I don't like where this is going already
okay well I'm not gonna stop there but
okay you clearly said that it wasn't
anything to do with nudity or anything
so I think maybe there was like a
reverse scene where the mom was bathing
you know Arthur this weird thing where
they would take turns bathing each other
I'm okay with that
but it just what's you're saying you're
not okay with the mother and son I knew
each other you could be beautiful but
it's pretty insane right like this is
insane and not pornographic not
pornographic the most insane part is
that it sounds like it's just like I'm
done now you go I'm done now you go
constant scrubbing till their mother
down to the theater for like 40 minutes
it was just for time
so he was insane isn't like people big
what is wrong with is the movie broken
why's it repeating the cycle yeah I'll
buy that that's a pretty insane theory
and also unsettling what else we got
okay so for it to be excessive of an
r-rating there does have to be nudity
involved insane dog he said he did say
not pornographic but if it exceeds our
rating by definition of MPAA standard
you know when you see it it's it's I
think there was some I just think that
was not alert and that's why but I think
really say erect yeah well mine is aware
of where it is right now but it's not
like ready to go well maybe you should
consult a physician it's at least one
Placid it's got to be like a bath tub
exit scene where like he gets off and I
just looked at the top my theory is that
it's he reenacts the bathtub scene from
The Shining and he is room 237 woman but
he gets up and he starts dancing with
Todd Phillips as Jack Torrance and then
he's like man because I'm a corpse
credits and that's why I didn't make it
in any sane but not pornographic
Erik I'm gonna make you I just I'm gonna
make you you can't have a break I'm
gonna make you say this one to get in a
tweet right now just to like focus is
down into what kind of gross you're
describing yeah did you know that Todd
Phillips deleted the scene from the
Joker that involved Joaquin Phoenix
re-enacting the shining but as an old
corpse man okay great clickbait be
enough for me i okay it's run to make
sure that it's not just the appearance
of more now it is straight up he's just
like much more than okay
all right insane well I don't really
want to have images pop into my head but
exactly I like walking lost a lot of
weight for that role and he'll it looks
almost like distorted as a person whose
body's just not right so my thing in my
rogue theory so I don't talk about
flaccid and bathing and nude mums
looking at nah awful but so I'm just
gonna go and think outside the box here
and use the fact that his body looks all
distorted and because it's actually not
human inside so while he's in the
bathtub and he's bathing the reason why
it's surpassing the r-rating is because
his skin starts splitting and opening
off of his body because he's actually
xenomorph julian yeah that became the
same but mad I'm gonna put it put one on
the line for you no but what if though
just had just take your okay it's fine
I'll just add what if though it's it is
that he like peeled his face off and
then he kind of like it gets up in the
mirror or something and he sticks it
back on in that famous Joker cementation
the stage cooling yeah podcast listeners
mod just pulled your bottom lip over or
entire bill in Silence of the Lambs it's
not there because it's tucked in between
but it's like that it's that famous
Joker look except it's also a fantasy
sequence so it's like so insane and
crazy but it's just another one of his
fantasies yeah that reference cut that
out though because it's too too insane
all right
never enough every guy named that
alright guys so who Eric's was the room
32:37 decrepit old Wang and then Tablo
run disappears as a tweet so arthur
flick loves his mom
babes her and mom returns the favor your
sounds very sweet our bar for weird has
done so like lost that that now sounds
like the fleck becomes flesh yeah
xenomorph i'll give both of you guys
also another one because okay I do like
these but if you remember correctly you
guys all wrote wishes and ended the
episode whoever's gonna end up with the
most highest total of bogies is gonna
get their wish to come true in this
episode but the game's not over yet
because we still have road questions to
go through what questions you guys
haven't seen oh that's right yeah then I
through the timeline you guys ready all
right it came out this week that Robert
Downey jr. his pitch for Tony Stark's
final line and endgame was oh snap pitch
me an even worse final line for Iron Man
I'm gonna die
it's pretty bad it's pretty bad good I
am gonna subscribe to Disney plus two
dollars every monthly this is the charge
[Laughter]
and then Mandalorian actors is the last
question Werner Herzog
an interview that he's never seen a Star
Wars movie what but but of course he
does watch WrestleMania
nothing wrong with he said that and it
was terrifying you've never seen another
Jon Favreau film
I'm sure that's also true he only
watches WrestleMania so let's hear your
best wrestling style smack-talk in your
best werner herzog voice everything he
says sounds like a threat yeah Internet
is a bottom line because stone and you
threw in some Snape evil and I'm feeling
that mod you get a block for all the
characters but for accuracy I'm gonna
whip out a silver block blocks are worth
it's an insane number it's the best car
Rogie the mandalorian yeah exactly
you can melt it down it's the equivalent
of get ready to row geese
[Applause]
I'd read but alright guys so the winner
of this one is going to be what are your
point totals for rookies three and a
half four and a quarter what uh four and
a quarter some mugs into em I'm gonna
take it real quick tablo sorry your wish
will never come true sorry for those
children Eric well we'll do this a
different time you can say this a lot
and then mods wish yeah this video has
to feature the tie in the title the
model Orion but spelled with mod in the
name as a pun because those will help
our SEO thanks mod broke theory thanks
for going over this thanks so much to
our guests Eric Foss and Maude Garrett
where can we find you what you up to
right now oh yeah look at Maude Garrett
on all things and I've got a bunch of
celebrity interviews for all the junk
it's happening in December coming out to
including Charlie's Angels and I
interviewed Robert DeNiro so yeah call
him Bobby duner now because we're
friends
I love dinero's new film and it's got
Pacino and Vito and and Taplow what are
you working on right now I'm working on
music with a group called epic high
which is my group it's amazing so check
it out and also I have a podcast called
the Tablo podcast where we just talk
nonsense everything is a rogue theory so
check oh sweet
that's fantastic guys music ow it's very
very very good and we're lucky to have
them thank you so much guys don't forget
to subscribe to the rogue theory podcast
feed it comes out earlier than the video
version stay tuned to the YouTube
channel for a bunch of cool stuff we
have coming out we'll talk about it
later
if somewhere else not in this episode
follow us on at nerves on Twitter and
follow me at Philip Malina wherever you
want to follow me in real life it's fine
have a good one guys
[Applause]
[Music]